it was reaction to all of tonight's
stories a lawmaker who is now calling
for a special counsel to investigate
Biden's classified document Scandal
Missouri Senator Josh Hawley Center
great to have you uh let's talk about a
special prosecutor why would that be
warranted here
because that's exactly what Merrick
Garland has done done to Donald Trump
and Sean as you were just saying a
second ago it can't be that we have two
tiers of Justice in this country it
can't be that there's one rule for
republicans and a different rule for
Democrats you know Merrick Garland said
oh we have to have a special prosecutor
for Trump well that means we've got to
have one for Biden it's the same thing
and arguably it's worse for Biden
because as you say he couldn't
declassify whatever else we know is true
we know that he didn't have the power on
his own as VP to declassify these
documents so listen the Democrats say
they're all for Equity well what's
Equitable here is that there be a
special counsel all right let's talk
about the other issues and the house
investigations that will be moving
forward we have Jim Jordan Judiciary
he'll be looking into the IRS I'm sorry
into the doj and the FBI James Comer
looking into the Biden family Syndicate
these are all stories you have followed
Anthony fauci the origins of kovid the
botched withdrawal out of Afghanistan
how important are these investigations
because the media mob Democrats they
want to dismiss them before they ever
get started
yeah they're hugely significant because
real oversight is what this
Administration hasn't gotten is what
Congress has not done and certainly the
Democrats in the Senate aren't going to
lift a finger to do anything so we've
got to get the truth Sean this
Administration has lied to the American
people about Afghanistan they have lied
about the IRS they've lied now about Joe
Biden and the classified documents
they've lied about what's going on at
the border they've lied they've lied
they've lied and it's time to get the
truth and to give it to the American
people the people deserve the truth they
deserve to know what's actually
happening in their government not these
constant lies which is what this
Administration lives by Senator let me
ask you what happened over Christmas I
couldn't believe my eyes here was an
opportunity for for Senate Republicans
to pass a continuing resolution but yet
they were held meant to go forward with
an Omnibus pill that had a lot of
Reckless spending by all accounts and
meanwhile they knew the Republicans in
the house would have a majority
Authority they could have worked with
the Republicans in the house they could
have got together and brought a budget
that was fiscally responsible that
didn't Rob from our kids and grandkids
why did your colleagues in the Senate go
along with this Republican colleagues
that is exactly what this that's exactly
what the Senate should have done Sean
you're absolutely right that's why I
voted against that huge budget bill it
made no sense to me at the time and it
still doesn't the voters just gave us a
republican house why in the world would
we not allow the house to start doing
their work and negotiate with Joe Biden
and actually get some budget priorities
that reflect the common sense of the
American people but you know Senate
Republicans and of course Senate
Democrats didn't want to do that it was
a capitulation it was a surrender and I
was totally against it at the time and I
can just tell you now as we come back
into session we have got to get some
guts and hold these people accountable
no more surrenders no more capitulations
it's time to get tough with the Biden
Administration yeah I totally agree by
the way uh now you have a fellow
Missouri Senator uh that shows great
promise uh and Eric Schmidt I think he's
going to do a good job your thoughts
me too oh absolutely I can't wait to
work with him he's going to be
tremendous and we've got a lot of work
to do there's a there's a lot of
accountability to be had Sean and
there's a lot of fighting we need to do
for the people of Missouri and the
American people all right Josh Hawley
thank you as always we appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else